(chants religieux)
- Tôt ce matin, la dépouille
du pape Benoît XVI a été
transportée à la Basilique
Saint-Pierre de Rome.
(cs)s)s)
Vêtu de rouge, la couleur
du deuil papal, un chapelet
entre les mains, il sera exposé
en chapelle ntntnte jusqu'à
mercredi.
Des milliers de personnes
défilent devant son ceililil,
certains se prennent même
en photo.
À l'extérieur, la file est
interminable. De nombreux
fidèles veulent lui rendre
un dernier hommage.
- Je l'ai connu personnellement
en 2006. Il y avait la visite...
Et nous sommes allés dans
la maison des papes, il n'a pas
suivi le protocole avec moi.
Il a commencé à parler avec moi,
ça a dépassé le temps. Il m'a
posé des questions sur ma vie
à l'université...
- Benoît XVI l'a profondément
marquée. Devenu pape en 2005,
l'Allemand Joseph Ratzinger a
renoncé à ses fonctions en 2013
pour des raisons de santé,
avant de s'éteindre samedi
à l'âge de 95 ans.
- Un tieieieien de renom basé
sur les pères de l'Église, et
puis un homme de vie concrète,
de simplicité évangélique.
- "Je suis très ému, dit
ce prêtre de la Zambie,
c'était un grand pape."
Sur la Place Saint-Pierre,
les curieux et les touristes
sont aussi de la partie.
- T'sais, on est en vacances
à Rome, là, pour quelques jours,
doncvevevevevement, on est venus
visiter ce beau monument et
du coup, bien, rendre hommage
aussi au pape décédé par
la même occasion ce matin.
- "C'est un événement
rassembleur, croit pour
sa part cette résidente de Rome.
Un moment qui unit les gens
dans la foi."
Les funérailles de Benoît XVI
seront célébrées jeudi
par son successeur,
le pape François,
une première dans l'histoire
de l'Église catholique.
Ici Olivier Bachand,
Radio-Canada, Montréa